pas une réunion entre nous il n'y a pas
de réunion informelle j'ai dit non non
la commission des lois est convoqué à
8h15 pour examiner
mais avant ça vous n'avez pas eu de
contact pour savoir avec les avocats si
les avocats font leur travail
naturellement que ce soit celui de
monsieur b d'al haouz monsieur traces en
particulier oui
donc il y à une commission des lois à
8h15 qui pourrait être amenée à examiner
une demande éventuelle de huis clos ça
va ma langue de bois est assez bonne
non j'avais dit ça veut dire qu'il est
contre expectative ça il peut y avoir
invité vous rendre compte la déception
de l'opinion publique des gens qui
souhaitent savoir ce qui s'est passé
qu'on a été choisi comme il suit une
demi-heure avant on sait qu'on n'est pas
sûr aux foules à savoir ce qu'ils la
commission moment le voir si la
commission des lois est saisie d'une
demande de huis clos elle devra statuer
sur cette demande
voilà je peux vous dire a plu ce serait
la première fois puisque y compris
monsieur creusa qui était mise en examen
n'avait pas demandé le huis clos mais
dans les règles de fonctionnement des
commissions d enquête
un auditionné peut demander le huis clos
est pas vous dire le contraire
et donc il ya un vote de la commission
et c'est la commission qui décide ou pas
d'accorder le huis clos en fonction
voilà deux critères mais aussi en
fonction de la jurisprudence de cette
maison est à vous c'est respectueuse à
titre personnel vous vous souhaitez même
à titre personnel si si la demande
devait intervenir de je ne sais qui je
suis très prudent quand même il est
évident que j'aurais à m'exprimer et que
je considère que cette affaire et ont
été tellement public vient d'entendre
marie pierre de la gontrie qui a dit
aimer jeu banal a été sur france inter
il a et s'exprimer dans le monde etc
j'emploie monde qui a eu à des images
vous avez vu voilà donc donc on a on a
effectivement une médiatisation qui est
très forte
je mesure la potentielle déception au
cas où mais excusez moi vous avez
entendu aussi mon collègue grosdidier
nous nous travaillons dans la sérénité
et donc avec tout le respect que nous
portons pour l'expression vise à nous à
titre personnel at-il personnellement je
serais opposé voiture et c'est je suis
un peu contradictoire vous allez me dire
mais non parce que je considère que nous
avons souhaité que ces auditions soir au
public depuis le début mai la commission
des lois en décidera souverainement en
tant que têtes
je pense qu'on nous devons la vérité aux
français en tout cas nous devons
contribuer à faire émerger cette vérité
à cette manifestation de la vérité
et je crois je crois la transparence
mais je ne veux pas non plus devant
c'est ce qui est le droit vous